Syvie boulanger bonjour nous sommes au
centre édition image centre national
édition à ré image he Chatou dont vous
êtes à la fois la directrice commissaire
d'exposition conservatrice ENF fa un peu
tout euh pas tout pas tout on est on est
à peu près dans on est dans l'Î des
impressionnistes alors euh un centre
d'art contemporain dans l'île des
Impressionnistes est un suivi normal
c'est une provocation c'est comment on
peut alors non c'estant pas une
provocation que les impressionnistes
eux-mêmes étaient contemporains de leur
époque voà donc on VI dans un suivi tout
à fait normal de la de la créativité
l'expression de la créativité
contemporaine depuis les
impressionnistes finalement mais c'est
vrai quand on pense à à l'île de château
on pense évidemment plutôt à Renoir
qu'aux artistes contemporains on a
peut-être tort on a peut-être t oui on a
peut-être t parce que quand on pense
c'est bien de penser dans l'actualité
aussi et c'est bien de vivre avec les
les artistes qui vivent en même temps
que nous c'est c'est c'était un
des une des risseau pour lequel ce
centre a été créé ici alors non ce
centre a été créé parce
que la ville voulait vraiment avoir un
espace créatif hein sur sur cette île
oui et puis le ministère de la Culture
donc a suivi le projet quand il s'est
rendu compte que ce lieu avait été le
lieu où a
travaillé Maurice de vlamin et André
dein d'accord voilà donc pas les
impressionnistes mais les fauvesuv et
c'est là où ils ont réalisé les
premières gravures fauve dans dans cet
espace dans cet espace qui était avant
une espèce de restaurant un peu louche
il faut l'avouer où il louait la la oui
oui où il louait un peu la grande salle
de restaurant qui était tout à fait
délabré qu'ils ont fini délabrer en
brûlant les chaises pour se chauffer
voilà parce que c'était quand même un
peu des des coquins et des voyoux de
rein et vlamin et voilà donc en fait il
y a une histoire de la gravure dans dans
ce lieu
voilà alors euh édition
art image euh il il y a trois donc il y
a trois plans hein TR tris trois trois
intérêts qui se rejoignent ENF qu'il
sont aussi différents oui en fait qui se
rejoignent beaucoup parce que au centre
en fait de de de ce faisau d'intérêt
hein qui qui est l'image qui est l'image
qui veut dire la reproduction en fait
l'idée de on est on est submergé d'image
on vit une société d'image donc voilà
c'est cette question là qui est posée
au-delà de la question de de l'art donc
comment l'art peut euh subsister ou au
contraire comment l'art peut rebondir
par le haut dans cette société de de de
l'image où on peut plus trop faire la
différence entre une image publicitaire
et une image artistique voilà donc c'est
ça un petit peu notre notre sujet et euh
et notre sujet c'est donc du coup euh
qu'est-ce que pourrait être l'art quand
il est reproduit parce qu'on dit
toujours l'art c'est unique c'est une
œuvre unique hein reproduction c'est mal
c'est mal c'est mal vu c'est un artiste
unique c'est un objet unique il a une
signature en bas qui la teste quand ça
sent encore la peinture c'est encore
mieux voilà parce qu'on est sûr que
c'est du vrai mais bon si tout ce qui
était pigment posé sur une toile était
de l'art ça ça serurait he là c'est ce
sont des expositions temporaires
oui oui moins fond existant alors alors
ce sont des expositions temporaires mais
nous avons deux fonds de collection que
l'on expose mais sous forme d'exposition
temporaire pour pas que ce soit la 100
pour le visiteur on utilise nos fonds
pour élaborer des expositions
temporaires mais ça c'est que
traditionnellement au dernier étage
d'accord donc là voilà là on
a une
exposition uniquement d'œuvres multiples
et qui pose la question du multiple et
par exemple la question de de la
variation de format donc à chaque
artiste voilà a été demandé en
fait deux œuvres finalement qui qui n'en
forment qu'une et qui deviennent trois
avec ce paquet de papier que vous avez
au sol et qui sont une image grand
format la même image réduite ça c'était
le cahier des charges et finalement la
photocopie de cette dernière
image disponible pour le visite
et ça c'est ce sont des œuvres que vous
commandez vous-même alors alors ça non
ça justement on a invité Mor publisher
qui est un groupe d'éditeurs qui fait le
même travail que nous qui commande à des
artistes d'accord donc on invite des
invités très bien dans cette salle là
dans cette salle voilà est-ce qu'on
voulez qu'on visite un petit peuons-y ce
qui se passe au
ét il est magnifique C escalier oui al
il été construit par Elisabeth bon et
Philippe Elisabeth lemcier et Philippe
bon les architectes qui ont refait tout
l'espace avec des ceintures de sécurité
ah d'accord et cet acier
galvanisé dont vous allez pouvoir voir
qu'il est utile pour tous nos
meubles alors nous sommes à l'étage là
oui là on est au premier étage donc
alors peut-être peut-être un mot sur le
sur le lieu d'abord dans lequel nous
nous trouvons oui oui donc alors donc
c'est un lieu qui était conçit au 19e
siècle sans aucun intérêt d'ailleurs
architecturalin et qui servait de de
restaurant voilà et et qui a été
réhabilité une première fois dans les
années 90 h h
euh mais bon il y avait beaucoup moins
d'espace
d'exposition voilà et puis là on vient
de de tout refaire en fait sur les
architectes bonat Le Mercier Elisabeth
Le Mercier et Philippe bonat qui qui
viennent de réhabiliter ce lieu avec des
principes tout simples tout est gris il
y a plus de blanc donc on homogénéise un
peu toutes les salles parce que on avait
le choix entre faire des White cubes
comme ça se fait régulièrement dans
l'art contemporain mais on trouvait que
ça convenait pas ici c'était pas c'était
pas juste ici ça ressemble à une maison
et c'était plus drôle de le garder comme
ça avec ces traits de lumière au plafond
qui sont très forts qui sont une
écriture très juste et qui apporte une
lumière du jour en fait à l'intérieur
d'une part on a construit a fait
construire par les frères boule kan et
ronand BR qui sont des grands designers
français une maison flottante qui nous
sert de de résidence aussi bien pour les
artistes les
écrivains voilà mais aussi des écrivains
aussi des curateurs voilà ils sont
résidence pour combien de temps c'est
complètement variable ça dépend du
projet ils peuvent venir TR fois 3
semaines ou ils peuvent rester de mois
ou ils peuvent claudde lévque est déjà
venu juste une journée pour filmer le
son des pénis chez des tankers qui
passaient pour sa pièce à
Venise ça dépend complètement du projet
on souhaite pas que ce soit des
résidences fixes ou maintenant les
artistes sont des Glob trotteurs ils
n'ont pas le temps de et et comment
comment il ils se portent candidat pour
être résident ici comment ça se passe
alors on ouvre là oui on va ouvrir un un
appel à projet effectivement un appel à
résident pour bénéficier des surprises
que ça va nous nous laisser mais jusqu'à
présent en fait c'est vraiment les
invitations des artistes qui vont faire
le programme puis puisqu'on travaille
avec une centaine de personnes par an
quand même quand Mme oui quand même
quandme quand Mme donc cette maison
flotante et puis et puis des des des
sculptures et puis à
l'extérieur justement c'est un des
artistes c'est yanana Friedman avec qui
on travaille maintenant depuis près de
10 ans qui a un jeune artiste de de 91
ans dans quelques dans quelques jours
et architecte utopiste et et qui a
décidé qui aime tellement le lieu qu'il
en fait en fait son terrain de jeu son
terrain d'expérimentation est-ce que
est-ce que derni avec plaisir
oui alors là on arrive dans on est au
dernier
étage ah oui j'ai compris ça parce que
j'ai vu que que le l'œuvre s'appelait
Mad
World STR voilà voilà voilà fou fou bon
et bon et étrange voilà monde en fait
c'est c'est le ça çause beaucoup parce
qu'on peut balancer des des on doit on
do on doit
jouerou oui oui oui d'ailleurs le le le
le jouet est quelque chose qui nous
intéresse beaucoup parce que
contrairement au au jeux le jouet n'a
pas de règles un jouet on doit inventer
ses propres règles alors qu' RG eston
balance ball les jouets les enfants
quand ils jouent invente évidemment les
meilleurs jouets c'est quand on invente
ses propres règles donc ça nous
intéresse beaucoup d'un point de vue de
l'art ça n intéresse du point de vue de
l'art ça c'est c'est intéressant du
point de vue de l'accueil du public
aussi non tout à fait tout à fait alors
pour l'accueil du public oui on
réfléchit beaucoup c'est compliqué la ou
ou oui c'est compliqué on adore ça on
adore ça alors le public vient de très
loin et de très près c'estàd qu'on a
environ un tiers du public qui vient de
de voilà de la
régionine voilà c'est ça non mais même
plus précisément en fait du département
et puis un/ers qui vient de Paris très
régulièrement plus les amateurs d'art
voilà et puis un tiers qui vient du du
mondortier parce que on a cette
spécialisation sur le livre d'artiste et
sur l'édition donc on a tous les
fanatiques euh de de ce champ là qui
viennent qui viennent nous voir on est
toujours très étonné et il y a des
rencontres avec les artistes oui oui il
y a très souvent des rencontres alors on
évite justement on évite justement les
les les les vernissages un peu compassés
et on a créé ce qu'on appelle des
festivals tout le monde est invité tout
le public est invité gratuitement
pendant un weekend entier où les
artistes sont là font des performances
il y a de la danse de la musique des
conférences voilà donc à côté quoi à la
fois didactique non pourraz dire ça oui
didactique oui c'est ça oui euh en tout
cas euh en tout cas on fait attention à
la transmission par exemple les les les
guides on évite les guides de de visite
voilà un peu trop arti et on invite
plutôt des écrivains à écrire leur
propre voilà leur propre guide de de
visite et à raconter ce que leur a fait
l'exposition plutôt que d'expliquer ce
qu'il faut penser est ce qu'il faut voir
on invite plutôt des gens à raconter ce
que ça leur a fait voilà et euh et et
justement là nous on est au dernier
étage mais euh à l'entrée même de de de
du centre il y a il y a toutes l'édition
toutes les éditions que vous faites hein
oui voilà on publie pas mal oui on
publie pas mal uniquement le livre
d'artistees pas de catalogue très peu de
catalogue donc pas de commentairire sur
l'art directement des gestes artistiques
toujours C boulanger merci infiniment de
de cette visite un peu courte mais voilà
il suffit de venir il faut venir voilà
pour prolonger merci beaucoup au
revoir